let me ask you the goat question again
from fantasy perspective
can you make the case for the greatest
chess player of all time
for each yourself magnus carlsen for
garrett kasparov i don't know who else
bobby fisher mikhail tall
anyone else um
for uh hikaru nakamura
just kidding yeah uh i i think i'll i
can make a case for um myself for for
gary and for fischer so i'll start with
fisher uh for him
it's very very simple
he was ahead of his time but that's like
intangible you can say that about a lot
of people but he had the peak
from
1970 to
72 when he was so much better
than the others he won 20 games in a row
also the way that he played
was so powerful and with so few mistakes
that
he just had no opposition there so he
had just a peak that's been
better than
anybody like the gap between
him and others
greater than it's ever been
in history at any other time uh and that
would be the argument for
for him
for gary he's played in a very
competitive
era
and he's beaten several generations he
was the best
well he was the consensus best player i
would say for
almost 20 years which nobody else has
has done in
at least in recent time and the
longevity that the longevity for sure
also at his peak
he um was not quite the level of um of
fischer in terms of the gap but it was
similar to or i think even a little bit
better than than mine as for me
i'm of course
unbeaten as as the world champion in in
five tries i've been world number one
for 11 years straight
in an even more competitive era than
gary i have the highest chest rating of
all time i have the longest streak ever
without
losing a game
i think for me the main argument would
be about the era where there's
the
engines have leveled the
playing field so much that it's it's
harder to dominate and still
i haven't always been uh clear number
one but i've always i've been number one
for 11 years and
for a lot of the time the gap has been
pretty big
so i think there are decent arguments
for for all of them um i've said before
and i haven't changed my mind that gary
generally urges it because of the
longevity in in the competitive era but
um
there are arguments but people also talk
about you in terms of the style of play
so it's not just about dominance or the
height or the
it's like
just the the creative genius of it the
yeah but i'm not interested in that
in terms of uh greatest of all time uh
i'm not interested in in
in questions of style
so you so for messi you don't give
credit for the style uh for the
stylistic i like i like um no i like
watching it i just but you're not going
to give
points for the
so messy no i mean
because of the finishing
yeah it's it's the um the no it's not
because of the finishing it's because of
his overall impact
on the game is higher than anybody
else's okay
he contributes
he just contributes more to winning than
anybody else does
what's um so you're somebody who was
advocated for and has done quite a bit
of study of classic games what would you
say is um
i mean maybe
the number one or maybe top three
games of chess ever played
that doesn't interest me at all you
don't think of the nose no i don't think
of it i mean i tried to i find the games
interesting i tried to learn from them
but like trying to to rank them has
never interested me what what games pop
out to you is like super interesting
then is there is there things like where
idea like old school games where there
was like interesting ideas
that
uh
um that you go back or like you you find
surprising and pretty cool that that
those ideas were developed back then
is there something that jumps to mind
yeah there are several games of
young kasparov like before he became
world champion
if you're gonna ask for like my favorite
player or favorite style that's probably
youngest youngest part can you describe
stylistically or in any other way what
what yonka's prof was like that you're
that you like uh it was just an overflow
energy in his play so aggressive yeah
exactly extremely aggressive dynamic
jazz
it probably appeals to me
a lot because
these are the things that i cannot do as
well
uh that it just feels very special to me
you